d'où sortent ces images parce que c'est
évidemment la première question qu'on se
pose en voyant ce film
ces images vous les avez prises où je
les ai toutes trouvées sur internet
elles sont en libre accès en réalité je
crois que qu'on les a tous vus plus ou
moins passé sans peut-être prendre le
temps de les regarder en tout cas moi
c'était mon cas j'avais pas pris le
temps de les regarder un jour je les
fais et
bon et j'ai pensé qu' il y avait là
quelque chose qui moi en tant que
cinéaste ne pouvais que me perturbée au
plus haut point qu'une caméra soit ce
point associé à un projet de mort est
donc alors si des sites c'est youtube
dailymotion des sites commerciaux mais
il ya aussi des sites de vétérans de
l'armée américaine sont donc les pilotes
eux-mêmes qui les zombies puisque les
pilotes sont tenus d'enregistrer deux
fils mais ils doivent remettre les films
ensuite à leur hiérarchie et et ils le
font sur une clé usb donc on peut
parfaitement imaginer qu'ils ont mis eux
mêmes des images sur internet
non seulement on peut l'imaginer mais
c'est vraisemblablement le cas il le met
directement en effet de leur clé usb a
aussi deux sur lesquels il est publié
les raisons moi j'ai pas interroger ses
pilotes là mais ça semblait il semble
être assez fier de la mission qu'ils ont
accompli peut-être que ça sert une forme
de de propagande indirects et que c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles
les états majors ne supprime pas ces
vidéos ce serait facile de ils les
laissent circuler au fond ce soit la
france ou les états unis
ces deux pays sont fiers de ces missions
puisque on en a jamais rougis non mais
s'est dit fière d'avoir été en irak et
on attend mais après ce sont des images
en principe qui ne sont pas faites pour
être regardé qui sont qui sont classés
secret défense c'est pas c'est moi gens
comme cinéaste j'en ai fait des images
que l'on regarde comme on regarderait
des images de cinéma mais pour le pilote
avec qui je discutais il comprenait pas
cette position et dix essais des images
strictement opérationnels qui servent à
viser à tuer
[Musique]